- [Instructor] In other
videos we talk about the rapid
spread of Islam, and one
of the interesting things
about these early Islamic empires
is they preserved much
of what they inherited
from the Byzantine and
the Persian empires.
The infrastructure including the roads,
the bureaucracy.
A lot of the culture.
And they also began to
collect the knowledge
from within the empire
and from the peoples
that they encountered on
the borders of the empire
including the Indians, and the Chinese.
And they did this throughout
the Umayyad dynasty.
But it really came to its full fruition
during the Abbasid Caliphate.
Now the Abbasid Caliphate,
one of the first things
they did under the Calph al-Mansur
is build Baghdad and move
the capital of the empire
to Baghdad.
Now one of al-Mansur's successors
al-Rashid, is famous for making Baghdad
a center of learning.
According to the historian
John William Draper
this is a sense of what life was like
under al-Rashid's rule.
During the period of the
Calphs the learned men
of the Christians and
the Jews were not only
held in great esteem, but were appointed
to posts of great responsibilities
and were promoted to
the higher ranking jobs
in the government.
He, Calph Haroon Rasheed, never considered
to which country alerted person belonged
nor his faith in belief
but only his excellence
in the field of learning.
And to get a sense of how much learning
and how advanced the knowledge began to be
especially under the rulership
of al-Rashid, during this time
he was a contemporary of Charlemagne
who was the Frankish king.
He was also the first holy Roman emperor.
And so it's this region right over here.
And they were trading gifts
and this is a historical account
Haroon al-Rashid sends
Charlemagne this water clock.
And it's so foreign to the Francs
to Charlemagne, that he thinks that it's
it must be some type of magic.
That it can't be explained
by just normal means.
And then things really
get invested in terms
of collecting knowledge
as we get into the rule of al-Rashid's son
al-Ma'mun where he creates in Baghdad
what is called The House of Wisdom.
Which is this center of learning,
of mathematics, astronomy, physics,
medicine, geography, and map making,
poetry, philosophy.
And, over the next several hundred years
these Abbasid Caliphs are going to
sponsor scholars from India,
learn it in Sanskrit and
the ancient Sanskrit text
in Greek, Chinese, Persian
to translate as much
of the knowledge and to collect it
in libraries in cities, like Baghdad.
To translate it into
Arabic, and to collect all
of that knowledge in one place.
And just to get a sense
of the type of advances
that occurred during
this golden age of Islam
which correlates strongly,
or is essentially during
the Abbasid dynasty and it
ends with the Mongol invasion
in the middle of the 13th
century right over here.
There are scientists like Al-Kwarizmi.
And Al-Kwarizmi is a Persian mathematician
and physicist.
And he's famous for being
the father of algebra.
The word algebra that we now have today
the subject you can learn a
lot about on Khan Academy
it comes from the Arabic word al-jabr
and his book al-Kitab al-mukhtasar
fi hisab al-jabr
wal-muqabala
which literally means, and
those of you who might speak
Arabic, or Persian, or even Hindi
or who might recognize Kitab as book.
And then hisab is calculation.
And al-jabr is an operation of completion
and it's essentially it's
one of the operations
we now do in algebra where you're doing
the same thing to both
sides of the equation
Balancing is also a
very similar operation.
He also brought the Indian number system
or the Hindu numerals.
He brought them to the Islamic empire.
And that was really the
bridge to bringing it
to the west.
Famously Pope Sylvester the second
he was educated in Catalonia
with the point of acquiring knowledge
that was gained from the Arabs.
Remember, the Arabs were in control
over the Islamic empires.
It was not the Abbasids
it was actually the
remnants of the Umayyads
who were in control of Spain at the time.
But because of that,
this area was considered
a center of learning.
And Pope Sylvester, who
got his education there,
he's the one that is
often given credit for
being one of the first to introduce the
decimal numeral system.
This Hindu Arabic decimal system
that we now use for our numeric system
as opposed to something
like Roman Numerals.
Well another very
interesting thing is not only
the word algebra comes from al-jabr
but the word algorithm is literally
comes from his name.
The name Al-Kwarizmi, Al-Kwarizmi in Latin
they pronounce as algarithme.
So other significant contributors to
the science of all of human civilization
are people like al-Marwazi.
Al-Marwazi, once again, in Baghdad.
And he would have been a contemporary
of al-Kwarizmi.
And he, if you've ever taken trigonometry,
or if you're about to take trigonometry,
he is accredited with coming up with
the core trigonometric functions.
We're talking about sine, cosine.
Tangent and cotangent
it might have been Marwazi or it might
have been another mathematician
named al-Buzjani who came
a little bit after, or a lot
depending on a human scale,
but was also based in Baghdad.
And together, they came up with the six
the six trigonometric functions.
They weren't contemporaries of each other
but they both made
significant contributions
to what we now call trigonometry.
Including many of the
trigonometric identities
that we now learn in high school.
Now you also have
physicists, mathematicians,
astronomers,
like Alhazon.
And he is credited as
getting one of the more
sophisticated views of how
light and vision works.
These are some quotes from Alhazon.
From each point of every
color body illuminated
by any light issue light
and color along every
straight line that can
be drawn from that point.
This is a fairly sophisticated
view of how light
actually works.
And he's also credited with
using and understanding
the scientific method
several hundred years before
the Renaissance in Europe.
The duty of a man, the duty
of the man who investigates
the writing of scientists.
If learning the truth is his goal
is to make himself an
enemy of all that he reads
and attack it from every side.
He should also suspect
himself as he performs
his critical examination of it
so that he may avoid falling
into either prejudice
or leniency.
And now another very
famous poet philosopher
mathematician poly math of the time
was Omar Khayyan.
And in the west, he's most
famous for his poetry.
Most famously the work of the Rubaiyat
the translation by Fitzgerald.
But he was also a significant philosopher
mathematician.
This is a picture of some
of his work right over here.
You can see that he did
his work in the 11th
and the 12th centuries.
And he did it from (mumbling).
But he investigated Pascal's Triangle
and the binomial theorem.
And keep in mind, this was over 500 years
before Pascal.
So maybe it should actually be called
Khayyam's Triangle.
And just to get a sense of
his poetry, or a sense of
the (mumbling) in general,
which I encourage you to
look up and read.
And this is at least
Fitzgerald's translation of it.
And that inverted bowl we call the sky
where under crawling
cooped we live and die.
Lift not they hands to it for help
for it rolls impotently on
as thou or I.
So as you can imagine, this Islamic world
these empires between the eighth
and 13th centuries, it was
actually a very powerful
bridge of human knowledge
taking knowledge from
the Indians, the Chinese,
the Ancient Greeks, and providing a bridge
during the Dark Ages in Europe.
And get a sense of that, we have some text
from some historians on that time period.
This is some text from
this is some text from
the historian Phillip Hiti.
And he wrote,
During all the first
part of the Middle Ages
no other people made as
important a contribution
to human progress as did the Arabs.
If we take this term to mean all those
whose mother tongue was Arabic
and not merely those living
in the Arabian peninsula.
For centuries, Arabic was
a language of learning,
culture, and intellectual progress
for the whole of the civilized world
with the exception of the Far East.
From the ninth to the 12th
century, there were more
philosophical medical historical religious
astronomical and geographical works
written in Arabic than in
any other human tongue.
And we also have a frame,
a point of view from
Bertrand Russell in his
History of Western Philosophy
who wrote,
Our use of the phrase the Dark Ages
to cover the period from 699
to 1000 marks our undue concentration
on Western Europe.
In China, this period
includes the time of the
Tang dynasty, the greatest
age of Chinese poetry.
From India to Spain, the
brilliant civilization
of Islam flourished.
What was lost to Christendom at this time
was not lost to civilization,
but quite the contrary.
To us it seems that Western
European civilization
is civilization, but this
is a narrow view.